[Music]
oh
right i'm ready
what just happened hello
i like money
[Applause]
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that's all about
soaking up knowledge like a sponge over
the years we've done our fair share of
spongebob theories from concluding that
spongebob was actually adopted to trying
to solve the krabby patty secret formula
but to this day there's been one
very popular theory that we've never
touched and that
is the nuclear mutation theory basically
the theory that all the sapient sea
creatures that we see on the spongebob
squarepants show are the result of
nuclear testing now that might initially
seem like a logical leap like why would
anyone jump to such an extreme
conclusion about the backstory of these
characters but when you stop and
actually look at the evidence there's a
lot here that adds up with the biggest
point being that spongebob's home is
called bikini bottom
named after the infamous bikini atoll
which as you may know is a group of
islands in the south pacific located
more than 3 000 miles or 5 000
kilometers off the coast of australia
basically in the middle of nowhere this
remote location prompted the us
government in the 1940s to say hey
this seems like a great place to test
our nuclear weapons and
boy howdy did they do a lot of testing
on those islands according to official
reports the united states detonated 23
nuclear devices during the time
including one in 1954 that was 1
100 times larger than the hiroshima
atomic bomb
in a lesser known part of the story
there were actually about 150 people
living on those islands that they had to
relocate during the period of testing
and then they sent back to live on the
island seriously in the 1960s there was
actually an attempt to resettle the
bikini atoll islands
something that ended in the 1970s when
they realized that um living on a former
nuclear test site
ain't great for your longevity it's
honestly a horrific story and also real
scary how little scientists back then
knew about the full ramifications of the
nuclear weapons they were testing and
that child friendly story is where
bikini bottom got its name
no theory there friends just pure fact
it is directly mentioned on the viacom
international website program
informacion for the show
and since it's common knowledge at this
point that radiation causes mutations
hey maybe these humanoid sea creatures
are the direct result
of said testing at the atoll so that's
the theory friends i've certainly heard
worse heck i've certainly made worse
in fact the theory was so good that it
got mainstream attention
back in 2017 when the huffington post
interviewed spongebob's voice actor tom
kenny they asked him point blank what do
you think about the popular theory that
spongebob is the result of nuclear
testing and rather than trying to dance
around the question he
confronted it outright quote well bikini
bottom is kind of named after bikini
atoll you know where they did nuclear
testing decades ago but i don't think
spongebob and his friends are mutations
i think bikini bottom is like its own
world when the camera drops below the
water and you go to bikini bottom it's
almost like it's another planet you know
there's never topical references in the
show
there's never an oprah joke or who wants
to be a millionaire joke or anything
topical or pop cultural in spongebob and
i think that helps keep it really
timeless and everlasting
end quote uh what never a pop culture
reference tom have you seen the show
that made you famous you've got
references to mary poppins
too bad you forgot your umbrella
a clockwork orange
otherwise known as number 655321
that iconic scene from rebel without a
cause
and sure those are just cultural
references but then again what about
this
how will we ever get back to bikini
bottom now i can take you there
who are you i'm david hasselhoff david
hasselhoff riffing on his 80s tv series
baywatch
yeah and regardless you have a squirrel
that's explicitly from texas
it's texas spongebob even sings the ever
so
humble there's no place like home
song in an episode i'm not trying to be
mean to tom kenny or anything i'm just
trying to establish that this is a world
that very clearly interacts with the
real life surface world thereby meaning
the bikini atoll theory has legs to
stand on horrific
disgusting mutant legs anyway that's his
opinion but again he's just the voice
actor could it be possible that stephen
hillenburg the show's creator
intended for this to be the case he was
after all a creator who was formerly a
marine biologist and cared about things
like humanity polluting the ocean
so why not start a series about the
pollution of nuclear fallout and that
sponge boys and sponge girls is what
we're exploring today
we're looking into both the science and
lore of spongebob to definitively prove
or
disprove this massive fan theory and let
me tell you this the final result is not
only surprising it's actually the first
time
something like this has happened on film
theory no joke a theorist
first so put on your best theorist pants
friends because i'm ready i'm ready i'm
ready
for a theory review leave your theories
in the comments below
i'll pick my favorites in the next
episode of morty
first sure it's named after the place
but is bikini bottom's location in the
show
plausibly near bikini atoll in the
pacific ocean
yes it has been proven time and again
that bikini bottom is
indeed in the pacific ocean in the
season 3 episode pranks a lot we see
sandy launch herself out of the ocean
and back to texas and she comes
from the east and in the spongebob
squarepants movie as our titular yellow
rectangle sings goofy goober rock the
camera zooms out of the ocean
specifically at the location where
bikini atoll is irl
it's not the most accurate of globes but
if this is australia
and that's north america here's where
bikini atoll is irl
and here's where they zoomed out of in
the movie yep it is definitely
real close even the sea life that we see
in bikini bottom lines up here we see
all sorts of animals large and small
filter through the town but large
permanent residents like pearl the sperm
whale yep bikini atoll is absolutely
within her range of habitat
blue whales like frank the whale yep in
range puffer fish like mrs puff
yep and on and on the list continues so
just from the initial check here yes
bikini atoll lines up both
geographically and
marine biologically with the places and
characters that we're seeing throughout
bikini bottom so let's now look at the
science of radiation
most media tend to treat nuclear
radiation like magical fairy dust that
just gives special powers to anything it
touches
why is the hulk green and super strong
radioactive blast where did peter parker
get his
spidey sense radioactive spider how did
professor x become a telepath
a radioactive bomb at least if you're
reading the x-men comics from the 1960s
yeah they've kind of washed over that
part of marvel comics history but in the
early days professor x was the result of
his parents working on the first atomic
bomb
anyway even spongebob the show leans
into this trope with the character
atomic flounder who's apparently so
radioactive that he can just cause
people to spurt extra mutant arms by
touching them with his nuclear touch
careful medical boy
he's got nuclear touch now of course
that's part of an in-world tv show that
spongebob and patrick are watching on a
vhs tape and not really canonical to the
true setting of bikini bottom but it
does demonstrate that the concept of
nuclear mutation does
exist within this fictional world which
then begs the question just how
realistic
is the trope this isn't just a
digression it's a question of science if
steven hillenburg wanted to ground his
show in some element of science just how
close to real science
is this concept well it's certainly far
off but also not as inaccurate as you
might expect i think we all understand
that nuclear radiation is bad and
dangerous right like i don't think any
of us are eagerly running away to roll
around in the dirt of chernobyl hoping
that we become the next jubilee a former
nuclear
testing site is generally not the kind
of place that people or marine wildlife
are going to want to live
nor the kind of place where they're
going to be able to thrive and build a
fully functioning marine society
well sure it is true that nuclear
radiation results in mutations
the vast majority of them are bad and
not just like
a little bad they're bad in a cause your
organs to stop working properly kind of
way
so does that mean that nuclear radiation
is a non-starter and trying to induce
beneficial mutation like we see in
spongebob
no because while most mutations are
actual death sentences it doesn't mean
that
all of them are see for instance the
atomic
gardening movement of the 1950s which
aimed to
intentionally induce mutations in living
plants by blasting them
with radiation now before you get too
excited about this being a way to help
your petunias grow it's important to
remember that most plants didn't fare
too well in these experiments
in gamma gardens as they were called
gardeners would arrange a 5-acre
circular plot with a radiation source in
the middle the plants nearest to the
center
usually died and most others featured
what researchers at the time described
as tumors or other abnormalities but
there were incredibly rare situations
where the mutations were actually
beneficial in nature
and you see that right there's the point
the breeders who are trying to develop
new types of plants didn't need all or
heck
even most of the plants to survive the
process their goal was to just take the
most genetically fit
or genetically interesting from each
generation and use those seeds to create
more of them it was essentially a way of
accelerating the process of selective
breeding instead of waiting for
interesting mutations to occur naturally
you artificially
induce them using radiation and
according to dr pierre lagotta of the
international atomic energy agency
radiation breeding has produced
thousands of useful mutants including
varieties of rice
wheat pears peas cotton bananas and
peanuts
and going back to bikini atoll for a
minute sea life seems to be returning
there
according to a recent article the place
is slowly coming back to life with quote
coral the size of cars as well as
schools of fish
and crabs that eat radioactive coconuts
all of this is to say that while the
spongebob nuclear testing theory might
seem absurd on its face or something
that would only work in science fiction
it
is actually based in some level of
scientific fact it is certainly possible
from a scientific angle that this theory
could work
except there is one big problem that
ultimately debunks this theory
and that's time because while the bikini
bottom nuclear testing theory does
indeed square with some real world
evidence what it doesn't hold up against
is the tv evidence the actual lore of
the show the entire basis of the nuclear
testing theory is that the intelligence
of bikini bottoms residents and their
ability to create a human-like society
is the result of mutations that happened
in the 40s and 50s when the island was
being bombarded with nuclear devices
the big problem there is that bikini
bottom has a history
far older than that in the episode
dunces and dragons we flash back to the
12th century and see that bikini bottom
back then bikini bottom shire was home
to a basic society of sapient sea
creature
don't hold thy breath we'll be lucky if
we get fed again by the 12th century
bikini bottomshire had the ability to
verbally communicate a basic system of
government
basic architecture in other words all of
signs of animal intelligence that we see
from them in the present day
centuries before us humans ever started
messing around with nuclear technology
at the end of the episode spongebob
tries to brush it all off as
some dream huh patrick but patrick
quickly subverts that worn out trope by
pointing out that one of the citizens of
bikini bottom shire the king's jester
squidly has time traveled back to the
present
along with them besides that spongebob's
reactions throughout the episode and the
existence of the medieval moment stadium
in the present day
confirmed that the civilization of
present-day bikini bottom has a history
dating back to the medieval era
12th century don't you see patrick we
really are in medieval times
and the history of unnaturally
intelligent sea life in bikini bottom
goes back even further than that
all the way to the prehistoric era
surely we all remember the primitive
sponge and primitive star memes that
originated from season one
what are you simpletons doing and while
these two might not seem like the
shining example of advanced animal
intelligence just take a look at them
they're wearing loincloths which mean
that they're sophisticated enough to
create clothing and while they haven't
developed a spoken language
squidward is able to train them to use
basic tools
we see the same thing in the episode
spongebob bc where prehistoric society
has advanced enough that we see basic
language starting to develop
[Music]
i could list more examples here but i
think you get the point usually in these
videos the lore leads us to a ridiculous
theory that eventually gets debunked by
science but this time it's actually the
exact opposite the lore
is the thing doing the debunking there's
no denying that bikini bottom is
inspired by and named after bikini atoll
and as we explore today the marine life
matches up the real world geography
matches up we know nuclear testing
happened there heck we even know that in
super rare cases
nuclear fallout can result in beneficial
mutation
from that perspective the citizens of
bikini bottom could absolutely have been
made into the advanced society they are
today
as the result of human experimentation
but the theory just doesn't hold up when
you actually examine the lore
of the series bikini bottom was advanced
centuries before humans discovered the
destructive force of radiation
an unexpected outcome to be sure but it
looks like the nuclear testing
theory just doesn't hold water or as you
might say
it's just a theory a film theory
and if you're looking for something that
does hold water or soda or milk look no
further than these reusable
dishwasher safe cups that we're selling
over on food theory that's right you
goofy goobers food theory right now has
merch which means that i now have
another bullet point on my modeling
resume in all seriousness though if
you're a fan of spongebob i recommend
you check out our latest food theory
episode where we
tested the double krabby patty with the
works in real life let's just say
it performed incredibly well as
incredibly as this food theory apron
looks on yours truly follow the link
below to watch that episode and check
out food theory merch because food
theory's got it all t-shirts reusable
cups aprons pizza plushies that's right
now you can have your very own slice
just like i had back in my theater days
so don't be a kelp for brains make your
theory dreams become a reality today
and cut
[Music]
you